[Musique]
eh bien au niveau du groupe il a été
signé un accord ou fonder les travaille
dans thales et donc on va on va
travailler avec les équipes pour
redéfinir les meilleurs modes
d'organisation entre présentiel et le
thé travail sachant que l'on estime dans
ou le tetra et doit doit pas excéder un
à deux jours par semaine sur le site
tombe on aura déjà déjà voir s'il est
nécessaire de maintenir un certain
nombre de principes des mesures
barrières et pour du coup dans ce cas là
on à date on adapte la configuration des
services des aménagements proposés et
donc le thé trahi par exemple à la base
notre côté trail potentiel sera sera
gérée à l'aune de ces
[Musique]
lorsque le 2 juin de la folie pour
demander un petit peu de temps pour avec
les équipes et s'organiser et donc on
visera à mettre en place une gestion qui
stabilise et probablement partir de
septembre